Meaningful use is a very important,
highly visible and
even controversial at times program,
that's divided into the three stages
that phase in over a period of years.
Stage 1 is about data capture and
sharing.
Things like electronically capturing
health information in the standardized
format, specified by the EHR
certification program.
Stage 2 is about more advanced
clinical processes, but
is similar to Stage 1, just more
ambitious and more sophisticated.
For example, the increased
requirements for E-Prescribing, and
incorporating laboratory tests.
We'll look at that in a moment.
Stage 3 aims for improved clinical
outcomes, which depends on more advanced
EMR functionality, such as clinical
decision support to guide providers.
And tools to help patients become
more involved in their own care.
Stage 3 is ambitious, and has recently
been pushed out to at least 2017.
Today, a majority of providers
participating in meaningful
use have achieved stage 1, and
are now focused on stage 2,
but only a small percentage
have achieved stage 2, to date.